you just earned yourself in detention
sir thank you he's already won me
[Music]
sir I don't understand that's glaringly
apparent I can't fail this class oh
don't tell yourself short Mr Coates I
truly believe that you can
every year at Barton Academy
as faculty and staff depart the campus
for a two-week winter break but there
are always an unfortunate few who have
nowhere to go for the holidays they're
known as the holdovers Mr Hannah hello
Mary I heard you got stuck with
babysitting duty this year how did you
manage that you know it used to be a
student right yeah that's why he knows
how to inflict maximum pain on them
I thought all the Nazis were hiding in
Argentina stifle if Tully
you've just earned yourself a detention
sir being here with you is already one
big detention son of a that's
another detention do you think I want to
be babysitting you no I was praying your
mother would pick up the phone or your
father would arrive in a helicopter or a
flying saucer father's dead
you don't tell a boy that's been left
behind at Christmas that nobody wants
him what's wrong with you
there's nobody here okay you stay out of
my way and I'll stay out of yours let me
sleep
most of the kids dislike you pretty much
hate you teachers too you know that
right I find the world a bitter and
complicated place and it seems to feel
the same way about me I think you and I
have this in common
I don't think I've ever had a real
family Christmas like this before
thank you Mary you're welcome history is
not simply the study of the past it is
an explanation of the present see when
you say it that way and throw in some
pornography it's a lot easier to
understand
I'd like to propose a toast to my two
unlikely companions
are you trying to look down my shirt
yes you're gonna get me fired
this is your Rubicon do not cross the
Rubicon
the holdovers
[Music]